hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday April 15th 2019 how you guys
doing today on this [ __ ] tax day huh
Oh Uncle Sam's not gonna you don't wanna
go Sam he's a [ __ ] he's taking all your
[ __ ] money unless you didn't do [ __ ]
and then he gives you a thumb I didn't
do anything this year Uncle Sam oh there
there here's some money for you hey
Uncle Sam I worked my balls off I'll
take that anyways I hope today finds you
on the fun side of tax day I hope it
does I hope it does you know it's funny
I actually found a [ __ ] w-9 or
whatever I have to go give to my
accountant and it's the 15th he's gonna
be like well where the [ __ ] was this way
[ __ ] I was asking where are you
[ __ ] Dobby [ __ ] nines for her man
my lawyer is uh he's a southern
character my lawyer my accountant how
are you guys how are you this morning
I'm actually you see how I didn't even
wait to see how you're doing because I
don't care oh it's all about me on this
podcast that's why I don't have guests
old freckles is [ __ ] wiped out this
is the thing about being a [ __ ]
redhead even when the red party ahead is
gone there's only so much Sun that
someone like myself can take on during a
48-hour period really only an eight-hour
period or I am going to be in serious
[ __ ] problems here and old freckles
spent the entire weekend out in the Sun
on Saturday I went to Long Beach and I
went down there and I watched the Long
Beach GP the Grand Prix down there
whatever the hell they call it's [ __ ]
amazing because not only was there a
couple of races there was also like
people out there trying to qualify for
the Indy
five hundred or something I didn't get
that part so maybe they were like
qualifying to try and qualify I don't
know how the [ __ ] it works but it was
kind of reminded me of like a mini
lamont where you got all these different
classes of cars that were out there
racing and it was so [ __ ] cool and I
got to go down you know go in the whole
pit area whatever the [ __ ] they call it
the paddock
they had BMWs and Porsches and Corvettes
and then they had more Indy Indy car
racing style cars and I got hooked up by
a good buddy of mine and he got this one
passed it said to take a hot lap which
really sounds perverted but you get in a
[ __ ] race car and the guy tears around
the track at about 120 130 miles an hour
now I had already done something like
that at the the Indy 500 that time when
when for with for all things comedy
comedy comedy I interviewed Danica
Patrick right before her last race and
she took me around in a Camaro so I
already did that and my lovely wife was
the one who kind of put together the
whole Long Beach thing so and I knew
that she was bored shitless so I was
like can you can my wife go instead of
me and the guy was like yeah that's what
she wants again man I've already done
this I you know I got I got to keep her
adrenaline going here and she ended up
jumping in this car and she got in some
[ __ ] Porsche which I guess was worth
like [ __ ] 300 grand and this guy tour
around the track she did a little
Instagram thing about it but um that put
a big smile on her face and got her
going again I don't know who she drove
with but uh she thought he was dead that
was his job that that's what the [ __ ] he
did and it turned out he was like some
like legendary racecar driver would want
a ton of races or something but anyways
we end up having a great [ __ ] time
and dude that I I've been meaning to go
to that that is a killer [ __ ] event
the crowd is like crazy into it and on
the first lap of the first race that I
saw there was uh there was an accident
we need to start the kragle Oh freaking
out because they [ __ ] were watching
it up on the TV and there's a couple of
hotels down there too for those of you
who don't want to sit in the Sun like me
that have balconies that overlook the
racetrack so it's like basically you
know you get high enough up a floor it's
like you're hovering in a [ __ ]
helicopter just watching the whole
friggin race and then he could have the
TV on in your living room you know what
I mean then he could burn some coal and
do a couple other things to [ __ ] up the
atmosphere just for your own [ __ ]
personal enjoyment it was tremendous I
had a moment there where I was almost
going to get to meet Bobbi ray Hall who
as far as I know is I think the first
guy who ever won a NASCAR event and then
won the Indy 500 that's quite a leap I
don't that you didn't see a lot back
then you know they were bunch of good
old boys back in the day hell it was
just running some carnage shining at
[ __ ] weekend before it was much more
like that I said I caught the tail end
you know Buddy Baker Cale Yarborough
Harry Gant you know arrogant in the
skull bein it whatever you have you be
with regal whatever the [ __ ] it was well
the [ __ ] car still look like
something you drive down the street I
caught the tail end of that Darrell
Waltrip bobby bonilla no I'm sorry
that's a baseball player isn't the [ __ ]
else was out there
Oh Bill Elliott the bilborough's [ __ ]
stock car drivers you know people always
said I look like Ron Howard it's like no
I didn't know I used to look like I used
to look like Bill Elliott aka dollar
bill which was never my nickname what
the [ __ ] am I talking about I'm wiped
out sorry and then Sunday when all this
unbelievable sports [ __ ] was happening
would Tiger Woods won the Matt
oh my god that was a scary moment all of
a sudden my mixer wasn't working and I
was like holy [ __ ] I believe I just said
oh no like now what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do
am I ever gonna go out buy another $60
[ __ ] two channel mixer its $99 a
guitar Sena it turns out it's just the
outlet in my house right I love it I
love buying an old house with character
it's got a lot of character you know see
that guy over there he doesn't work at
all he's got he's got a lot of character
he doesn't have a [ __ ] job that guy
has a lot of character it's weird how
like the way human beings you're not
judged having a lot of character if you
don't have a [ __ ] job but you know if
a house doesn't work at all it's that's
how it's described got a lot of
character it's got a great personality
anyways Tiger Woods won the master
ladies the ladies all these years they
were hoping that that [ __ ] would
never win again so there's stupid
[ __ ] theory that you know you know
women always try to take the credit when
I'm when a great man does something
whenever a great man achieves something
what do they try to [ __ ] do they go
well these T's wife supported him so
when she [ __ ] leaves him when the guys
old and he's limping around and all that
he can't hit a jump shot anymore and she
goes out and takes his [ __ ] house
they always try to say well she gave up
on her dreams to follow her yet cuz her
dreams couldn't sell out an arena here's
one for you ladies I don't know why I'm
coming at you like just because it's fun
you know what it's fun you guys are just
getting your [ __ ] asses kicked by all
these man Chinese out there right now
sitting there [ __ ] interviewing you
specifically white women like you have
difficult lives which is just [ __ ]
hilarious to me but it also is the
genius of a woman you know what I mean
the manipulating
hours of women is to such a high level
their skill and manipulation is such to
a high level that literally white women
are being interviewed on television
right now like there's some sort of like
oppressed people what is it like to be a
white woman in the United States of
America that has to be so difficult
you have no idea every day when I wake
up I look at my SUV and I'm like it
needs to be vacuumed out anyways there's
that big [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] argument
about support whenever somebody great
specifically a man does something great
and then a woman cleans them out or this
credit you know or the guys given a
[ __ ] speech he always asked to thank
his [ __ ] wife you know what I mean
and you know we all guys we know what
this is say her [ __ ] name so she's in
a good mood on the car ride home because
God knows her emotions come first before
anything else in the [ __ ]
relationship so that's why guys are
given a shout-out but what women do is
they take it at face value like they
actually had something to [ __ ] and do
with it you know what I mean ladies let
me ask you this [ __ ] question okay
because for all these [ __ ] years they
had this theory that when Tigers
personal life fell apart that's why his
golf game fell apart which was complete
horseshit all right if you're ready any
of those stories the men definitely had
the ability to compartmentalize his life
[Music]
that wasn't the issue from day one when
he was just a kid when he won his first
math master-master right when when that
[ __ ] in 1997 all these [ __ ] old white
guys were going like this guy's
unbelievable he's gonna [ __ ] do this
and yet but a day the way he swings it's
such a violent swing I'm worried about
his back and his knees and all that they
called it a lot of them were probably
hoping it was gonna happen because they
wanted Jack Nicholson or Nicholas sari
to still be at the top you know who's
kidding who golf isn't the exactly the
most inclusive [ __ ] sport out there
right so they laugh
no personal cutler like they said person
of color baton [ __ ] the coldest sucks
the sun-god Jack Nicholas so they were
predicting that his his body was gonna
break down and give out on which it did
right when his personal life did so of
course everybody gives the Barbie doll
all this [ __ ] credit that she was his
rock she did the [ __ ] out of here
the guy did it on him by himself that's
it he did it on his own at the end of
the [ __ ] day she's not out there
swinging the [ __ ] yardstick all right
you know and for any women who don't
like that [ __ ] let me ask you this okay
what a woman gives birth and a guy
sitting there supporting or going come
on you can do it okay who deserves the
lion's share of the credit when the baby
gets delivered furthermore who gets the
lion's share of the credit the woman
still does you know any but you can
better believe if we were pushing a kid
out of our heads there and the woman was
cheering us on you know God knows God
knows the court system would be like
well you know she played a major role
how come fans and for the Patriots
haven't gotten their own Super Bowl
rings for supporting the Patriots
through this incredible Super Bowl run
team where's my ring I supported you Tom
Brady hmm so anyway I'm just I'm really
talking to a small segment of [ __ ]
women out there but it's fun to [ __ ]
trashin I missed the whole [ __ ] thing
I didn't see any of it and I was I was
at Fort Irwin out in the Mojave Desert
in Mojave Desert watching the army play
some war games don't ask me how the [ __ ]
this whole thing came together I did if
I did a show at an American Legion
there's a comic there John site sugu is
a veteran himself and you just go down
there and you're smoking cigars with
veterans and they ask you [ __ ] and you
just keep saying yes the next thing you
know is a bald redheaded male you were
see were out in the middle of the
[ __ ] Mojave Desert
no business being out there [ __ ] in
the middle of the guy who actually we
got up at like 5:30 12 you had to be
there at 5:30 in the morning it's pretty
cool
we flew like a vietnam-era Huey like the
apocalypse now one you know Charlie
doesn't like to surf you know we flew
that thing up out there I got to sit in
a Blackhawk and our patch II talked to
all these pilots and then I watched a
[ __ ] war game and hate the [ __ ]
military meal that they have out there
that you know you cut it open with a
knife and there's some [ __ ] psycho
thing that you I don't know kind of rub
it together and then you stick the chili
in and it heats up I gotta tell you it
was pretty [ __ ] good all right
granted I wouldn't want to eat that
every goddamn day for two [ __ ] years
in the middle of god-knows-where I
wouldn't want to do that but you know
for one day you know it's funny I'm so
Hollywood they were like you know what's
funny is this this meal here is actually
5,000 calories because these guys have
just [ __ ] sitting out there these
brave men and women are sitting out
there right for 10 days they're out
there so then you know they're burning
all these calories and [ __ ] and
immediately I'm so Hollywood like 5,000
calories I have an acting gig coming up
and I can only eat about 1875 that's my
target ah but I ate the whole [ __ ]
thing I didn't want to disrespect
anybody
so anyways watch these whole [ __ ]
wargames and it was uh it was
fascinating they like played it's almost
like laser tag and they get like these
blinking lights on like tanks and [ __ ]
like that and if you get hit and it
blinks twice it's considered not a
direct hit but you're you I don't sort
of wounded and if it blinks for times
that means you're dead you're out of the
game your whole tank shuts down you're
not able to communicate with anybody
because you know theoretically you
[ __ ] dead and I just watched how the
Black Horse the home team they drew in
the other tubes basically in a way game
for the other people and I kind of left
the end of the day learned a lot of [ __ ]
I don't know a lot of [ __ ] but I learned
a lot of [ __ ] like how that terrain is
fought in and it's basically you
through the valleys you're not gonna try
to go up and over certainly with all
that you know equipment which isn't
something that I ever even thought about
so you just kind of know alright where
can they come from and then they just
basically draw them in you know it's
it's like hey look at this over here and
they go after that and then they get I
don't know what the proper terminal ank
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is they
hit him from the other side okay look at
my left hand and then they punch him
what the right was essentially what they
kept doing and it was working
they kept drawing people in like you'd
see them they spot their position the
other team would get excited and they
would just [ __ ] come flying in guns
a-blazing and then they would just get
broadsided and by the time they figured
out where the fire was coming from it
was over they were [ __ ] I got to go in
an old tank and I shot a well you know
that gun on top the turret let's hurry
time whatever the [ __ ] it is that little
thing and you know what I realized in
that moment I could give a [ __ ] about
guns and I am all about aviation I was
hanging on every word of those pilots
asking them how you know the whole thing
worked why the tail rotor was that much
higher than the main rotor I could have
talked about that all day long but
[ __ ] sitting there my ears a shot I
don't want to see you know it was like
doing that you know something every
[ __ ] redneck would get half a woody
to go do and I was up there I felt
guilty I was just up there like jeez its
Christ how many bullets are left my ears
are ringing [ __ ] I was more fascinated
with how you change the [ __ ] if one
of the the tracks comes off the tank how
you changed that [ __ ] thing and what a
[ __ ] it is to change and how long it
takes and how [ __ ] pissed off
everybody gets I was more fascinated
with that although the [ __ ] weaponry
on the the Apache was pretty cool you
know that thing that things on the side
where it's just like they it's like a
circle thing and like they just kind of
knowledge [ __ ] comes out when the pilots
are saying yeah the
things are about as accurate as a bottle
rocket so it's really like this big
skill to try and to initially try to get
some sort of accuracy with those things
but anyways we spent like god we got out
there like seven something in the
morning and I took pictures with a lot
of the troops out there and as you
noticed it was [ __ ] hilarious I kept
it real I came out there dressed like a
civilian I wasn't gonna go to the
army-navy store like a friend of mine
did but he was a veteran and buy some
[ __ ] camouflage pants I walked out
ahead like the Spicoli vans on I didn't
realize we were going out in the middle
of the desert
I had this this [ __ ] windbreaker that
my wife bought me for Christmas I've
only worn it like five times I don't
know how I'm going to get it clean but I
want to thank everybody out there Fort
Irwin I'm definitely gonna come back and
do a show if I can figure out where to
do when I didn't see where they had any
sort of a theater or a stage or anything
but I definitely I was talking to John
sites that I go to we got to come back
out and do a show these people are great
they treated us awesome and I don't know
that was that was quite a goddamn
experience like if I was gonna miss the
Masters and see Tiger win because I know
I can watch that on online I'll be able
to find it but I heard it was the most
exciting master since Nicholas in 86 but
I don't was amazing and what was killer
was every [ __ ] army guy a woman that
even remotely knew who I was said hey I
love f is for family not one of them
said didn't think about my stand-up
which was so [ __ ] cool so I'm kind of
feeling like after three seasons at F as
a family it's finally break and throw
anyway so thank you to everybody out
there for Norman I want to come back out
and do a show all right not in the
middle of the [ __ ] desert
I need a stage and an air-conditioned
bunker you give me that and I'll be I'll
be back out there other than that I
maybe I'll go out there in the
wintertime I'll do a nighttime show when
all them creepy critters come out
I guess there's some turtle out there -
that's like endangered so if they come
upon it they're supposed to let people
know and then they come out and they
remove it and they stick it somewhere
else and the big joke is the reason why
is in danger just because if you come up
and you try and pick it up its defense
mechanism is it empties all the fluids
out of itself bodily fluids and then
like it dies of like dehydration
immediately it's like well I mean if
that's your defense is to essentially
kill yourself I don't know how long you
can be around I would I wouldn't assume
that that would be something you could
do alright anyways congratulations to
Tiger Woods I when I got off you know
when I came back to uh you know the
helicopter we were gonna fly back I
turned my phone back on and uh you know
I had all these messages from virzi and
bartnik and all these guys flipping out
about Tiger I was like oh my god you got
to be kidding me
and so I immediately looked up Tiger
Woods and I saw that picture of him when
he sunk sank the puck the putt sank the
putt and I can't remember the last time
I was that happy for an athlete cannot
[ __ ] remember so [ __ ] great and
now he's got like what 15 or 16 and Jack
has 18 if he at 43 puts it all back
together I mean jack 1-1 in 86 he was 46
years old so he can definitely do it
but and I thought I remember seeing him
I watched the beginning of the Masters
and I saw him he looked like he was in
really good shape
it's just I mean how great is that for
golf I can't imagine what the [ __ ]
ratings were and then the amount of
jackasses who are now gonna go take up
the game that guy has been the greatest
thing for golf you know of the last you
know quarter century like he's basically
had the sport on his back so it's so
great to see that guy come back
congratulations Tiger Woods and
congratulations to your Boston Bruins
tying up the series the mapley first the
the birds okay it's a tale of two
different gates this is my takeaway from
both games I would say in Game one the
Bruins got lulled into the Maple Leafs
game up and down into end [ __ ]
defenseman getting caught up ice
whatever the [ __ ] they were doing we let
up like I felt like six breakaways they
had a breakaway goal and then they
scored on a penalty shot it's just like
what the [ __ ] is what this isn't how we
play and then in game two I thought the
Maple Leafs got drawn into the Bruins
physical play and you know I thought of
both games both like the Bruins lost
their composure in the first game and I
thought the least kind of lost their
composure in the second game as far as
like not sticking to their game plan and
getting drawn into it's like watching a
boxing match and a boxer gets drawn into
the center of the Ring for a brawl you
know cuz the other guy kind of gets him
into that macho [ __ ] mode so game 3 I
would assume is tonight like I said I
was kind of off the grid this weekend
and by the way I got to look it up right
now what the [ __ ] is happening down in
Tampa that is the only [ __ ] time
after Game two when Columbus beat beat
the Lightning there's the only time I've
ever seen was it Tortorella it's the
only time I've seen that guy smile like
that like he looked elated oh my god
they are you [ __ ] kidding me and he's
[ __ ] over I was just gonna say
Columbus has to win Game three because
you can't wake the sleeping giant that
is the Tampa Bay Lightning good [ __ ]
lord I gotta watch the NHL Network what
is what are the Columbus Blue Jackets
doing that the Bruins couldn't [ __ ]
do playoff shot Columbus wins again goes
up three nothing okay he
some quotes everyone's got to step up
everyone's got a place solid solid game
and we've got to make it a little bit
harder that was Tyler Johnson I don't
know who that is I don't know anybody is
I got a kid now I don't know who [ __ ]
plays for who alright Game three Steven
Stamkos now I believe he's still playing
with Tampa he said they have no power
plays in a game is pretty surprising
you have to earn those and I thought we
played well in the third but it's no
consolation right now with the position
we're in sort of complaining but not
really focus has to be coming out and
playing with that same pace the same
execution that same desperation right
from the start play one period at a time
said Ryan McDowell where the [ __ ]
these people are somebody asked the
question when was the last time Tampa
won a Stanley Cup why that would be 2004
that would be 2004 Jesus Christ you know
I went to a game out there in Columbus
and I was very impressed with their fans
and that was early on they were all in
they were into the [ __ ] game so
congratulations to them Tampa Bay
Lightning fans [ __ ] I've been there
guard knows I've been there I've been
there as a fan well you [ __ ] kicked
the [ __ ] and left my first year watching
the Boston Bruins like really luck no my
first year I went to a game was that 83
season 80 was at 83 84 we won the
Presidents Trophy or something we had
Pete Peters and he was like the best
goalie in the league and all of that and
the first round was best three out of
five and the Canadiens came in and they
were like fourth place in the Adams
division and we drew them and those
[ __ ] [ __ ] came in and swept us
like they always did back then and the
first game that was the first Boston
Bruin game I ever went to I was taking
French and the French kids had come over
and they took him to a game and he had
to buy the tickets through our French
teacher was pretty cool and we all went
down to the old Boston Garden and
remember we went in there and we were
sitting with the French kids and it took
me about eight seconds to realize that
those [ __ ] [ __ ] started rooting
for the Canadians because they have
started hearing all that blue Blanc a
Rouge and all that [ __ ] which is so
[ __ ] ridiculous because the French
don't even respect the [ __ ] French
Canadians they don't consider them real
French they consider them farmers but I
gotta hand it to those French kids they
will [ __ ] wave in these these
Montreal Canadian flags right in the
faces of these drunk [ __ ] Bruins fans
in the upper deck but I think because
they were French and they just weren't
an American jerk-offs they somehow got
away with it but I remember my French
treats our teacher looking over at me
like making this face like did these
[ __ ] kids know what they're doing
this is getting pretty intense oh my god
with that been hilarious if a brawl
broke out in the next day we went to
[ __ ] French class you know it'd be
hilarious is nothing would happen as far
as like back then where now that would
be like a national news story like what
was that French teacher thinking
bringing these poor immigrants down to
that hostile environment look at this
cell phone footage that wouldn't happen
do you realize I grew up in an era where
something like that could have happened
and knowing the people in this section
would not even have known the backstory
of what went down they would have
thought it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] who came down from Montreal and
got their asses kicked
they wouldn't realise now that was like
teenagers from France anyway so Game
three I imagined is tonight a huge
[ __ ] game huge game we got to take
control in goddamn series Toronto was
such a good team and I was not believing
in their goaltender there that Anderson
guy and basically I watched one game and
he mishandled the puck twice so I was
like I know about hockey but he's been
playing great certainly in that first
game that first game we had like I felt
like we had 20 more shots than least it
and they still came in and won so Leafs
have a really good team and I really
like the Leafs you know what I mean
always have
so like I said if we don't beat the
Leafs in this series that they're gonna
be the team that I'm gonna be rooting
for
although Columbus I mean that's a fun
story now if they beat Tampa Jesus
Christ and I haven't seen a second of
that series I'm missing the whole
friggin thing I'm running around like a
lunatic why why is that because we got
the last episode of efforts for family
for season four we're writing it this
week but what happens at this time of
the season is as you're writing the
episode you're also getting the first
animatics which is the first rough
drawings and then you have to go back
and punch that stuff up and look at the
edits so it starts to become like rather
than one giant wave writing the script
it starts becoming a series of waves
hitting the beach and old freckles gets
busy here but uh I definitely got to
tune in to watch that game for that
Columbus series and and of course I'm
gonna be watching my Bruins tonight all
right what else Oh big announcement this
is something I've been trying to do for
a while I have a charity show coming up
on August 1st at the Wilbur Boston
Massachusetts yours truly is going to be
there with a bunch of other Boston
comics it's for the the Travis Roy
foundation it's laughing with your
buddies for the Travis Roy foundation
Travis Roy of course was great hockey
player for the Boston Bruins and
unfortunately you know he broke his neck
and got paralyzed playing for the team
and I remember where I was when I saw
that story that story really affected
everybody living in Boston and I was
I've been trying to get involved with
their charity for a long time and it's
finally gonna happen and this is
basically yeah the you know it's the
most important show I'm doing one of the
year man this is that this is a huge
thing to be able to do something for the
Travis Roy foundation has been able to
email back and forth with him he's a
great dude obviously
with a great heart super positive and
he's doing such great things for people
who are in a similar situation as him
it's gonna be August 1st at the Wilbur
theater the venue presale is Wednesday
and Thursday tickets are on sale Friday
[Music]
ww-will Bert WI L P you are calm /
artist / bill burr bill - / another
backslash Jesus Christ why don't we just
[ __ ] tweet the goddamn link I think
that that's what we're gonna do I can't
wait to do that show old freckles is
going to have a fun summer I got a got
an acting gig and that shoots back on
the East Coast some of you saw my
General Hospital trailer so that's a
first soap opera actually released a
trailer but I like to think I did such a
good job
on General Hospital that they they want
to hype my three-episode arc it's
actually just one episode all right and
then new to all things comedy check this
out all things comedy going
international here alright this is the
copy to all my Mandarin speaking
listeners which I hope there's some the
Mandarin dream podcasts would think
child funk child instead of running that
funk cha a Beijing born Los Angeles
comedian I met him the other night at
the Comedy Store he talks about his
experience growing up in a culture that
didn't worship American comedy to being
right in the middle of it as a comedy
store employee and stand-up comedian
it's available on iTunes Spotify Google
Play and YouTube and this podcast is
basically it's in Mandarin and in
English and we're very excited that he's
come onboard here at all things comedy
and open us up to I don't know a billion
possible new listeners over in China so
what's up to everybody mainland China
welcome to all things comedy I hope you
enjoy his podcast
if he can find a way to listen to it
because I'm not sure you know I know
they black out the [ __ ] internet over
there from what I've heard as far as the
American propaganda done told me I don't
know if it's true or not
all right let's read some of some of the
advertising here for the week for hims I
asked you do you want a bald spot to pop
up on your hairline I'm sorry do you
want a bald spot to pop up or your
hairline to recede or do you want to do
something about it first why do guys
turn to weird solutions because they
don't want to go bald or do nothing
because they've dealt with it they
accepted it that's how I dealt with
balding I [ __ ] I acted like that
[ __ ] turtle out in the Mojave Desert
I just [ __ ] rolled over and died
anyways when they can turn to medicine
in science this really is like a thing
like I guess you don't have to go bald
anymore it's funny the other guy I was
working with it was also bald and we
were talking about him he was going he's
getting those old age spots on top of
your head I said no [ __ ] way dude I
do not have my bald head in the Sun
whatsoever and he goes yeah man it sucks
and then we just started laughing I go
you know it's [ __ ] crazy with all
this stem-cell research they can
literally grow a [ __ ] ear and a
goddamn petri dish and they can't come
up with a solution to balding and and we
were both laughing about I go yeah but
you know it's [ __ ] funny once she
shave your head like I don't think I
would want to go back there is something
great if you shave your head you're
always ready to go all you got to do is
throw on a shirt with the that's [ __ ]
ironed and you look like I don't know
you had a spa day this is probably not
[ __ ] to be saying in a solution for both
don't end up like me talking to another
bald guy in a parking lot after being in
a desert all day acting like you like
looking like a [ __ ] poor man's yul
brenner
anyways no more work no more anyways for
hims calm is a one shop for hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men this
is basically us this is just putting the
entire male ego back
together okay they're gonna give you a
lion's mane of hair they're gonna clear
up your skin your dick is gonna be
standing up at attention what the [ __ ]
more do you need no more awkward
in-person doctor visits along pharmacy
lines oh that's the worst I went to a
couple of those when I was considering
trying to do something about my
situation
you just sit in the waiting room look at
another [ __ ] balding guy's and you
try not to make [ __ ] eye contact for
hims connects you to real doctors online
which could save you hours completely
confidential and discreet online answer
a few questions a doctor will review and
they determine if if it's right for you
can prescribe you medication to treat
hair loss that is shipped directly to
your door get the hair loss treatment
everyone is talking about featured in GQ
Men's Health Esquire and Playboy to name
a few my listeners can get started with
the hims complete hair kit for just five
dollars right now while supplies last
and subject to doctor approval see
website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or a pharmacy
somewhere else go to for hims hims
dot-com slash berm that's fo r hims com
slash bur for hims calm slash bar all
right only one other read guys lastly
but not leastly better help is there
something that interferes with your
happiness or is preventing you from from
achieving your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you better help offers
licensed professional professional
counselors who are specialized in issues
such as depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts LGBT matters grief self
esteem Jesus Christ and more it seems
like a long list shorten as needed it
says in a parenthesis why you guys
[ __ ]
kind of doing everything over there
Sasquatch shapeshifter whatever your
[ __ ] problem is connect with your
professional counselor means in a safe
and private online environment anything
you share is confidential online and
it's so convenient people okay both of
these things are great for hims and
better help
nothing is confidential online it's
confidential until somebody [ __ ]
shares it or get you get your [ __ ]
site hacked all right online security is
is the this decades the the checks in
the mail all right you can now get your
own help you can get your own time at
your own pace well you can get help at
your own time at your own pace you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
plus chat and text with your therapist
if you're not happy if you not happy
with your counselor you can request a
new one at any time no additional charge
best of all it's a truly affordable
option and for my listeners get 10% off
your first month in discount code burst
so why not get started today go to
better help calm slash bar simply fill
out a questionnaire to help them assess
your needs and get matched with a
counselor you'll love better help calm
slash bar all right what else did I want
to talk about was there anything else
Lewis Hamilton once again finally had
his first read great start of the year
blew right by valtteri botas who had the
pole position and that was pretty much
it and I've been watching Racing f1
racing long enough to know that when
Lewis Hamilton gets to first in that
first turn the [ __ ] race is over it's
over and I also know that if he's in
second a third place and there's only
ten laps to go and he has no chance of
winning the race he's going to start
complaining I don't understand why other
people aren't helping me out here I was
really hoping botas was gonna win that
because I didn't realize the first year
when I watched what a great [ __ ] year
that was to watch two drivers on the
same team compete for it and not help
each other and smash into each other
what the [ __ ] was that guy's name the
guy retired I can't remember his name
anyway
plowing ahead I did not see the MotoGP
race I have a lot of [ __ ] to get caught
up on because I was out in a desert I
[Music]
was being such a [ __ ] [ __ ] when I
was out there too
like they were explaining all this
military stuff to me and I was just
standing there and my [ __ ] vans and
my my Pete Carril khakis and they would
explain all this military [ __ ] and then
they would just be like do you have any
questions and I was just like kid I bet
the stars that night are incredible out
here can you see the stars a lot better
than you can without the thing and the
[ __ ] it was a guy when Special Forces
and he totally rolled with it he was
like absolutely it makes you question
your existent we're just a speck of dust
yeah there was a lot of ball breaking
out there and it reminded me of back in
the day when I used to work in a
warehouse and all we did was just give
each other [ __ ] all day was the most fun
[ __ ] thing ever and at some point
because one of the guys on Special
Forces was also had a kid around my age
we both started going off on that show
Fancy Nancy and and what an [ __ ] she
is and how we both are watching her
going like this I don't want my daughter
watching this [ __ ] and they watch it oh
cuz she's fancy and she's totally into
like status and who her friends are and
having tree forts and not letting people
in and it's trying to fill up her life
with like [ __ ] clothes and [ __ ] like
that's gonna fill up her passion and we
would just trash in it laughing our
asses off and at some point we said that
the working title of that defer the
working title of it was actually Kunti
Cathy but they couldn't get it on the
air or something like I forget but we
just [ __ ] sitting in the middle of
this desert just laughing our balls off
about this [ __ ] cartoon and then all
of a sudden this wargames thing started
and I don't know I want to thank
everybody once again
without them and that was a hell of an
experience that I will definitely not
forget so anyway all right let's see
let's read some of the questions here
for this week all right okay so I sent
out a tweet as a joke saying you know I
wish somebody from England could explain
to me the different leagues in soccer
and I was doing that as a joke because
last week when I [ __ ] thought that
Man City had lost a league game and that
what's-his-face is you know it's so
[ __ ] stupid it's not a [ __ ] league
game but they still add the points or
don't have the points I don't [ __ ]
get it it's so [ __ ] ridiculous like
this is just a friendly the middle of
the season let's just play a [ __ ]
game for the [ __ ] of it and then there's
the Champions League anyway so I have
all these [ __ ] English [ __ ] put down
their fish and chips for a [ __ ]
minute right and waddled they're bloated
upper bodies with this skinny [ __ ]
legs over to their computer and just
started it was hilarious they were
[ __ ] livid at me and so I was just
sort of being a dick and going I wish
somebody would explain it to me some a
if I could see if I could get them to
start writing in capital letters but
what ended up happening was because I
wrote it nicely rather than being a dick
here so I still got [ __ ] sand in my
throat they actually sent me a bunch of
emails to try to explain it to me so now
I can't break their balls anymore so
alright so here's the deal this is
basically explaining all the different
leagues soccer has has a playoff but
it's called the Champions League the top
four Premier League teams at the end of
the season make the playoffs just like
the divisions in American sports see I
didn't know this the team with the most
points in the Premier League
basically wins the Presidents Trophy the
biggest difference is that the playoffs
happen at the same time as the regular
season seemed like that I needed more
explanation so that basically means that
this season is a playoff all right so
the tottingham we
over man city happened in the playoffs
what Liverpool is currently in the
playoffs and there are no tie games if
you get a chance watch the Champions
League it's really awesome to watch
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself yeah now see
I would watch that now why didn't
somebody just tell me that for the
beginning but the Champions League is
also it's not just the top four teams I
thought there was something like with
like Switzerland I don't know I'm just
gonna keep asking questions till I get
it because now that seems that seems
exciting to me as opposed to just you
know well we met twice during the
regular season and I lost both [ __ ]
games but I still have more points to
you so I win the Premier League I don't
I don't know anyways um this is Biden
dear Billy Knight nightshades
I'm not offended by your take on Biden
because I don't really get offended and
I'm not outraged by by Biden okay so now
you know immediately this person's gonna
[ __ ] be offended my opinion however
is different than yours which despite
what they tell us on the new the news is
ok alright I would take another look at
the video of him groping sideboob and
[ __ ] if that was a guy I work with I'd
have the same opinion and it happens
when the guy is next to a podium not on
the dance floor sending signals some of
the girls are young it's just weird and
I'm not even saying he's got bad
intentions you just can't touch
strangers that long haha and I totally
understand the it was from a different
time thing but my dad never rubbed up on
people and he served in Korea and drove
a Cutlass love you and love the podcast
oh here's the thing about the Joe Biden
thing I didn't even see that I saw like
half a clip before I went out on Conan
they go you want to talk about that yeah
I'll [ __ ] talk about it I don't pay
attention to [ __ ] I'm just so [ __ ]
sick of everybody having their [ __ ]
career ended on on a [ __ ] you know a
two-minute tripping
penalty and everybody else sitting there
[ __ ] acting like they're good people
as I said from day one if everybody's
[ __ ] text messages were made public
could anybody go to work next Monday
nobody nobody could so everybody's got
to stop [ __ ] like this [ __ ] witch
hunt that like you know for your own
[ __ ] into the thing to the amount of
people they're gonna watch Biden's dream
of becoming president get destroyed just
for the entertainment purpose of it
that's all they want to do and there's
another thing too is because there's so
many different ways to just sit down and
watch [ __ ] there's so much [ __ ] to
[ __ ] watch there's so much weight and
so many ways to watch [ __ ] that one of
ratings grabbing is [ __ ] stirring up
controversy Jesus Christ do you remember
the [ __ ] family feud richard Dawson
was like tongue-kiss and every [ __ ]
chick on the goddamn [ __ ] thing there
was no [ __ ] problem he hosted few but
[Music]
it was fine
everybody [ __ ] sitting there getting
uncomfortable it didn't happen to you
nothing happened to you this isn't your
[ __ ] story
if the woman's uncomfortable she should
say something
jesus [ __ ] christ oh you matter that
[ __ ] where it's just like so-and-so said
this but did they really mean that
should peyton manning be upset well he's
obviously not upset ESPN i remember that
one from back in the day i don't know
i'm one of these [ __ ] people that
it's just like if that's between the
[ __ ] people involved i don't know
what their [ __ ] relationship is and
neither do you
for all you know he was maybe the side
boob chick he's [ __ ] banging and
afterwards she's just like dude what the
[ __ ] don't grab my tit on [ __ ] TV
they're gonna know we're [ __ ] banging
there's a possible scenario look at me
with no evidence I can do it too yeah
I'm not in the [ __ ] business a
[ __ ] making up [ __ ] and trying to
[ __ ] get people in trouble am I maybe
I am as a comedian I don't know I just
feel like I'm [ __ ] joking around and
like this this [ __ ] thing will you
just shove a microscope up everybody's
ass they're all human
they're all [ __ ] flawed I remember
back in the day when I worked in a
warehouse there was this [ __ ] manager
guy he was too [ __ ] touchy-feely and
you know what we all [ __ ] dealt with
it it was [ __ ] hilarious when he'd
get you and everybody else would just be
laughing at you but nowadays that guy
would lose his [ __ ] job he'd have to
be a registered [ __ ] sex offender I
remember I used to [ __ ] try to make
sure I was like you know you had to have
your head on a swivel when that guy
[ __ ] came and big [ __ ] Doughboy
looking dude right so I was at the
vending machine and I was I was I I've
told this story before I was trying I
figured what the [ __ ] I was trying to
buy some [ __ ] food or whatever and as
you do it a vending machine and he came
walking and he goes oh hey Bill how you
doing as he was walking by me from left
to right he slapped his hand on my left
shoulder and then dragged it across my
entire back as as he was walking past
and then squeezed my right [ __ ]
shoulder like it was a perky titty like
he was squeezing the Charmin and I was
just like I mean it took like a decade
and a half to [ __ ] shake that thing
off now should that guy have been doing
that no do I think I need to report him
and he should [ __ ] then lose his job
and then this is on him for the rest of
his [ __ ] life now he's just weird
he's a weird guy okay he didn't [ __ ]
diddle me drugged me and throw me in a
van
he [ __ ] he [ __ ] yeah no he got a
little too friendly he gave me the
heebie-jeebies
okay now I don't think giving somebody
the heebie-jeebies should [ __ ] end
your career
I think you ought to be able to sit down
with them and be like listen could you
do me a favor
can you just say hello like granted he
was man sorry granted he was my boss and
I was younger and I didn't know how to
[ __ ] say that but I mean you know
what it [ __ ] Jesus Christ every
[ __ ] thing everything is just the
biggest oh you know what I did I went
back into the warehouse and I [ __ ]
told everybody and I got such a big
laugh telling the story it was almost
worth that that he did it the fact it
was worth it I don't get I didn't give a
[ __ ] I didn't feel [ __ ] triggered and
all of that [ __ ] crap every [ __ ]
thing you know but I got to tell you
something right now anybody fought in
Korea and drove a [ __ ] olds cutlasses
alright with me all right
white people challenging racism hey mr.
Billy Baldwin
I like that that's a new one play on the
Baldwin thing but what people done that
before but that's in a different
different way right anyways I'm a fellow
Masshole that used to work in the
athletics department don't call me a
math Hall it's just shaming an entire
state and I feel like every state bring
something to the table speaking which
Fort Irwin
I learned when I was there the square
mile e square mileage the square miles
of that training facility that base is
bigger than the state of Rhode Island
how crazy is that anyways the class or
the [ __ ] am i I am a fellow Masshole
that used to work in the athletics
department at a small college in one of
those rich suburbs of Boston
hey they in already a buddy I wanted to
hear your opinion on a professional
development class that I was forced to
go to
[Music]
the class was titled white people
challenging racism to middle-aged women
ran the class one white lady that had to
mention that she had a black husband
every other sentence and the other a
black lady who referenced the book that
she wrote every other sentence oh my god
this is like a sketch I wish I was there
long story short the class was about how
the only people that can be racist in
America are white people because they
hold the power over every minority
they're big finet you see wrote their
big finally their big finale was showing
a video from the 90s of a high school
science teacher showing kids that all
people share the same DNA and we're one
race which I mentioned yeah they taught
me that in middle school social studies
in science class I thought everyone knew
this the black professor also came over
to me and my coworker after we had
finished reviewing and said you two look
like you don't want to be here my
coworker and I looked at each other and
explained how we had finished the work
she just assigned which was to point out
how the video she showed us was racist
overall it was a very uncomfortable
experience and I was just wondering how
you were to responded in this training
sorry for the long email love your stuff
and hope you and your family are well
from a fellow Masshole all right okay a
lot of stuff here all right
the wording of that is so stupid to say
that white people are the only ones that
they have the ability to be racist is
because they hold the power over other
every other minority is such a stupid
[ __ ] way of conveying that thought to
a group of people that you want to be
receptive of that information that's
immediately going to put every white
person on the defensive and be like what
the [ __ ]
and then start sending [ __ ] email
questions to some [ __ ] podcast who
sits in his basement and talks to
himself I would have worded that
differently I would have said that the
reason why white people being racist is
the worst is because they hold they do
hold the power over every other minority
so the effect of them being racist is so
much more painful all right and if I was
in that class what I would have said I
would I would have said is what you what
you're saying and I'm not saying this is
with all white people because not every
white person is in a position of power
but overall all the powerful positions
you know 99.9% of them seems to be held
by white people what I would have said
what I would say what I have said to
people you know when they try to come
out with that white guys are evil [ __ ]
it's like no they're not they're not
inherently evil what you're seeing with
white people is human beings with
unchecked power the result of that okay
so what you would then see is if another
group were to get that power they would
behave in the exact same way and what I
would say is the me2 movement if you
look at how these powerless women then
handled the power of being able to
destroy you know first of all get-get
people who did something wrong all and
then how quickly that's spun out of
[ __ ] control to just like I was in a
toxic relationship which who the [ __ ]
hasn't been who the [ __ ] can't look on
back on that dating history coming like
Jesus Christ I should have got out of
that relationship [ __ ] two dates in
and then we would have avoided all of
that [ __ ] drama of screaming and
yelling sure but that me too [ __ ] went
from like these [ __ ] horrible guys
that were taking their dicks out and
doing all this [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] to
then just like he yelled at me you know
in and
you just saw how that that whole [ __ ]
thing has spun out of control I thought
uh I don't want to [ __ ] stir up the
name here again how a certain [ __ ]
group prevented a certain [ __ ]
performer from doing a dream gig this
year I thought that their unchecked
power that they went from despite the
fact that they became a an entity to
protect victims they actually became the
bully in that point where this person
had already [ __ ] apologised so there
needs to be more of that because the
ultimate goal is to get white people to
understand the position of somebody who
isn't white so when you come at people
that way that's that that's how it's
done on the Internet in a more crass way
which I've always said is when
somebody's presenting an opinion they'll
be like hey [ __ ] maybe if you
[ __ ] blah blah blah blah blood they
start with hey [ __ ] like who's listening
after that so and it's weird cuz I
understand the first huge fights I got
in with Patrice O'Neal when he said it
was impossible for black people to be
rate I was like what the what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
and and then I later found out he was
quoting like Spike Lee and it wasn't
even his quote but that hold that whole
thing where that woman came over to me
and if she if she came home II said you
two look like you don't want to be here
you got to go right back at a person
like that you two looked like you don't
want to be here and I would be like and
I would just look at the way I go what
is that based on and I would throw it
right back at her so now you're coming
over here judging me and my vibe and
you're coming over here with like this
aggressive thing with this this veiled
sort of I'm gonna report you because you
weren't sitting here with the big smile
on your face what do you want me to do
now be reverse Louie Armstrong while I
listen to this [ __ ] is that what I'm
supposed to [ __ ] do you told me to do
this and I did it this is the thing like
but you're not allowed to say that in
that it's like well you kind of came the
whole [ __ ] way you entered this was
not the way that that's just not the
[ __ ] way to do it
you know and then if somebody's up there
while they're doing that also trying to
sell books the whole thing is [ __ ]
hilarious you two look like you don't
want to be here I'm sorry I was thinking
about where the nearest Barnes and Noble
was so I could go out and buy your book
do you have any sort of guilt that
you're trying to make money off of this
yeah so here's the thing I see I see
both sides of that like like white
people challenging racism that's a weird
title for what happened I thought that
that was going to be like you know when
white people do that thing when somebody
a black person talks about racism and
they go like slavery was like eight
years ago
[ __ ] get over it like they do that
[ __ ] like I thought that that's what
this email was gonna be about which
obviously is astoundingly ignorant and
it didn't affect so many people's lives
it would be actually funny on some
[ __ ] level yeah so that's my take on
that so if anybody does that like the
big thing about when you're presenting
an opinion and God knows I learned this
by doing it the wrong way for [ __ ] 40
of my 50 years is you have to enter your
point in a way that keeps the other
people's deflector shields down so they
can hear what you're saying and then
also feel that you're not saying that
they are the thing that you're talking
about that would be my suggestion and
when you're doing that you know I don't
know I that [ __ ] lady they're just
sitting that sitting that going because
I got a black husband I've written a
black dick so I feel like I should be
here we need a white person that's
halfway into the black world here to
maybe help the white people that are
fully in the white world to bridge the
gap between themselves and then this
african-american woman here who's gonna
try to inform them while selling books
alright Titanic theory alright hey Bill
hey there Billy false-flag do you know
the theory behind the Titanic sinking in
short JP Morgan owned the Titanic and
the Olympic completely identical ships
the Olympic was damaged in port before
it could be insured according to a
shipyard captain at the time Morgan had
all the identification changed so it
said Titanic on the now weep weakened
Olympic get the [ __ ] out of here
Morgan was supposed to be on the ship
but fell ill at the last minute
important side note this was all while
Morgan was fighting for a central
banking system so we can manipulate US
markets even more also the voyage on the
voyage were two billionaires who opposed
the federal system and stood in Morgan's
way there's a lot of good info on this
one Billy would love to hear your
thoughts I'd love to read about it what
you're basically doing here is you're
presenting motive alright where he would
definitely have a motive if all of that
is true but how do you prove the old
switcheroo which is what a lot of
conspiracy theory starts off with and it
reminds me of this great Robert Klein
joke when he was making fun of those
people at late-night that would tell you
how to get rich and he would start it
off he goes okay you have no money so
you buy a house and then you take the
equity in the house you don't own and
like it all starts off with this giant
leap of [ __ ] like wait a minute I
don't have any money how do I buy a
house how do you how do you prove to me
well the Olympic was damaged in port
before it could be insured I mean how
bad was it damaged
though III don't believe this I don't
believe it oh yeah I simply don't
believe that so what had already had
holes in it and then they just sent it
out I know I don't believe that and also
I think the people the way they examined
the boat when they found it
I didn't everything kind of fall in
place yeah I don't believe that the old
me would have believed that yeah but me
from 10 years ago would it believe that
but I'll look it up that's that's
fascinating [ __ ] that makes for a great
I'll take for a great [ __ ] movie all
right high school sweetie reached out to
me oh Jesus dear bill a longtime
listener of the podcast seen all your
specials look forward to season foa of
ephesus for efforts for family
I am 22 and have been listening to the
podcast for the last five years
tremendous the other day I literally put
myself in that put you in my shoes like
if all of a sudden if you were 50 in
your high school sweetheart reached out
to you how weird that would be because
both of you would be married or divorced
that would be crazy anyways I am 22 and
I've been listening to the podcast for
the last five years the other day my
high school sweetie texted me out of the
blue explaining that I was on her mind
and she couldn't hold back her feelings
of curiosity so she texted me well that
was smart that's what she should do you
young this is all this is all aboveboard
no no Biden no Biden no sideboob I now
live in a different City have a new
girlfriend and my ex and I haven't
spoken in over a year
oh so you only broke up with her a year
ago I thought you haven't talked to her
since high school
okay in the past she has reached out to
me when she's having difficulties in her
current relationship and in my opinion
would text me to test the waters to see
if I was ready to get back together with
her and of course things would always
escalate to the bedroom her texts went
on to say that the next time I was in
town we should get together for coffee
or something and quote catch up I was
skeptical but played along
greed wait you have a new girlfriend
here man I don't know about this but
she's young this is what you do I was
skeptical what played along and agreed
she then went on to say that she has the
cutest puppy and I just have to me all
right now she's drawn you into her house
or apartment and I was even more
skeptical of her true intentions Jesus
you're acting like the white guy in
every [ __ ] horror movie when I was
growing up I need to investigate I asked
her if she still lived with her current
boyfriend and she said no it's
complicated so bill would I just be dumb
to actually meet up with her and chat
with the thought that maybe she actually
wants to catch up or should I just stay
away reaching out to you because you've
always been great with advice in
relationship which wish you and your
family all the best all right let me get
to the top of this thing here I now live
in a different city and have a new
girlfriend all right you have a
girlfriend dude so you should know you
should not be doing this would you be
cool if your new girlfriend was [ __ ]
catching up with her old old boyfriend
who got a new goldfish and wanted her to
come by his apartment to check it out
you know what she wants to do I know my
listeners know and you know your dick is
taking you over there buddy you don't
seem like you you didn't mention one
time that you still have feelings for
this woman at all I think it's some
[ __ ] throwback [ __ ] that you're
going to it's not fair to your new
girlfriend you shouldn't [ __ ] do it
unless you still have feelings for this
woman at which point you should not be
in a relationship with this other new
girlfriend you should figure that out
but all is forgiven because you're only
22 years old
you know and you have a dick so these
are tough years as a guy you don't know
what the [ __ ] to do so no I would not go
I would you know if I could go back and
talk to the 22 year old me I would say
don't do [ __ ] like this especially now
okay well you have social media and all
that and there's nothing preventing her
after you hook up with her which you
know you're gonna do there's
nothing preventing her from [ __ ] you
know when she finds does she know you
have a girlfriend she probably doesn't
and if she finds out there's that you
know you're gonna get caught the whole
[ __ ] thing's gonna blow up in your
face you know and that's gonna be it
so I would not do it I wouldn't do it
it's not fair to the girlfriend that you
have but um I don't know you the weird
thing about all of this is I don't think
you're into either one of these women I
think you should be single because you
have a new girlfriend you didn't say
that I love that's [ __ ] awesome and
blah blah blah blah you didn't say that
and then you didn't say that you still
love your ex I think you're trying to
[ __ ] both these chicks is what I'm
thinking I I wouldn't do it I wouldn't
do it and I would also try to assess how
you feel about your new girlfriend
before you waste her time and break her
heart you might want to be single he's
one of them I'm leaning towards that I
don't have enough information here but
that's I didn't see any sort of uh you
know my high school sweetheart I felt
like I could be with her I thought this
was the one I never heard that and I
never heard that about the new one so
I'm just gonna keep saying the same
thing over and over again so good luck
with that situation sir it's a trick you
want all right that's the podcast
everybody I'm gonna watch the MotoGP and
get caught up in support some sports and
try to catch the Tiger Woods masters at
least some [ __ ] highlight something
of it once again travis roy tickets
foundation tickets go on sale the
presale is this freaking wednesday and
thursday I'm going to sorry tweet the
link Instagram it and all of that [ __ ]
Facebook it and please come down it's
going to be a great great night a stand
up for a great foundation and that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
ya on Thursday